why
so amazing spider-man issue number 534
is a very important comic regarding
Peter Parker and the reason why is
because this really kind of gives us
this internal struggle that's going on
with Peter Parker really kind of gives
us maybe this internal struggle
regarding his feelings of loyalty
towards Iron Man but his hero worship of
Captain America and he's really kind of
stuck in the middle and and really kind
of is questioning whether or not what
he's doing is the right thing to do
now as the story unfolds as a story
begins to open up we see that this comic
book takes place after the events after
the conflict between Iron Man and
Captain America and their respective
teams at the chemical plant and what we
see is that Iron Man is really kind of
telling his team that they are going to
be transporting the captured heroes from
the conflict at the chemical plant to a
secure location now at this point we
don't know where that location is
although we will find out later on
however what we see is that Peter Parker
is noticeably silent he's really kind of
quiet here and when the meeting comes to
an end of course iron man asks him about
this he asked him why he's being so
quiet and Peter Parker really a Peter
Parker really kind of gives an ominous
answer here
he says there's really nothing going on
and that he understands what it is that
they're all basically just kind of
following orders and as the story
continues you really kind of see this
inner monologue going on with him we of
course see that Iron Man and his team
begin transporting the heroes and that
as Peter Parker I guess encounters
various individuals as they began to
kind of leave the their current location
that they are met with both supporters
and protesters and the crowd is really
kind of split in half and Peter Parker
really kind of finds it weird to be
called Peter Parker he really is always
addressed as spider-man and so for him
it's very strange after so many years to
hear people who don't know him in his
personal life to refer to him as Peter
in addition he really kind of has this
personal conversation with himself where
he talks about how he's on the side of
law he's on the side of the rule that
had been laid down but he just feels
like this is wrong
that something just doesn't feel right
about what it is it's going on as they
begin to kind of progress of course
Peter Parker asked
Ironman why it is that he's not out in
front leading everything and he's really
not scouting around and looking for you
know potential threats later on down the
line and the reason why is as far as
Ironman gives it is because Peter Parker
has a spider sense and a spider sense
grants him the ability to know a threat
before it's coming whereas everybody
else can only react to threats once once
they make themselves known
now Peter Parker is really kind of
concerned by this and the reason why is
because he's never told Iron Man that he
has a spider since no one really knows
that except for maybe a handful of
villains that he's fought and of course
Aunt May and Mary Jane and so his
concern is that Ironman may very well be
using this suit to the suit that he's
given him to really kind of track him to
really kind of monitor him and to gain a
lot of information on him and so for
Peter Parker he really kind of used this
as a concern that Ironman has taken
liberties that he really wasn't allowed
to take what we also see here is that
spider-man senses cloak-and-dagger
Captain America daredevil and Luke Cage
tracking the the crew tracking Iron
Man's group from the sewers now
spider-man doesn't in fact know that
these are the individuals that are
tracking them they just simply aware
that his spider sense is going off and
someone is following him now of course
we see that is Captain America Luke Cage
cloak-and-dagger and daredevil but you
know we're really not sure what
direction things are going to go at this
point now what we see of course is that
spider man tells Iron Man what's going
on that there were individuals following
them but Iron Man doesn't want to engage
in a fight while they're transporting
prisoners and what we're not necessarily
given a direct reason for this I would
go as far as to say that if there were
some kind of a conflict and for some
reason those superheroes were to become
released from their containment trucks
then most likely it would be a vast
number of superheroes siding with
Captain America against the relatively
small contingent of people that Iron Man
has taken with him now what we see is
that Iron Man takes it it makes a
decision to really kind of take a backup
route and they end up on Yancy Street
now if you guys recall our video
about the Fantastic Four specifically
about Ben Grimm we talked about how
Yancy Street is an area of New York
where it is really a large home to
people who were avidly against
superhuman Registration and so for the
most part Iron Man's team has really
kind of gone into the Lions Den here and
we really kind of see this playing out
we of course see the Captain America and
his team make themselves known and they
directly combat Iron Man and spider-man
and so on and so forth but what we
really kind of see here is something
that I think is very intriguing as a
direct confrontation between spider-man
and Captain America now the
confrontation is an immediate Captain
America offers spider-man a chance to
side with him of course spider-man turns
this down and then he begins to fight
Captain America and this is really kind
of interesting here because we really
kind of see the hero worship that
spider-man had for Captain America for
so long we see that for the most part
spider-man is entirely outclassed by
Captain America you know spider-man even
goes as far as to say that Captain
America has knowledge and hand-to-hand
combat that spider-man could never gain
over the course of his lifetime and
Captain America is really kind of always
one step ahead of everything spider-man
does now towards the end of the fight
spider-man begins to realize that the
flaw in his fighting with Captain
America is that he is fighting Captain
America man-to-man as opposed to
fighting Captain America spider to man
of course we see Captain America's
shield is chipped away but shortly after
this Captain America actually bails out
on the fight he takes off and the reason
why is because he hears that his his
team is really kind of struggling
against Iron Man's team and so he takes
off to help his friends from there we
see a Spider Man really kind of go
through this entire inner monologue this
entire inner debate where he's really
kind of discussing this with himself
he's really kind of talking about how
Captain America's shield represents
America it represents the laws that we
laid down and while not every law that
we like is fair not every law that we
have to follow is right that these are
in fact the laws and the laws do have to
be followed now ultimately he leaves
Captain America's shield clung to the
wall where Captain America can later
come back and find it and some of the
ending lines that we see is really kind
of Peter Parker again questioning
whether or not he's doing
right thing by really kind of sitting
that he really hopes he's on the right
side so Civil War frontline issue number
four continues are really kind of a
journey I guess with Sally Floyd and Ben
Urich along with Robbie Baldwin in
addition to the events that followed
after the destruction of Joe's marina
and as we begin to kind of progress
through this story we see that Ben Urich
and Sally Floyd are meeting yet again at
a coffee shop and really just kind of
talking about the superhuman
Registration Act and their roles as
reporters and so on but where we had
previously talked about the kind of
evolution where these individuals would
begin taking sides
this comic really kind of brings us this
instance where Sally Floyd really kind
of goes full-on against registration and
what's really kind of interesting here
is that Ben Urich is really kind of
taking the center of the road here he's
really kind of telling her that their
job as reporters is not to be an
objective it's not to take sides their
job is to simply just report the news
their job is to report what's there not
what they actually think is there and
Ben here it kind of talks about how if
you allow yourself to get caught up if
you're not in a position where you can
kind of disassociate yourself with the
events going on then you'll really kind
of go crazy and he really kind of gives
us a flashback to when the Silver Surfer
first appeared in Marvel Comics and he's
talking to us about how he had been on
the job for about a year or so and he
had been working in sports with regards
to the Daily Bugle and the whole
reaction the whole instance of an
extraterrestrial life invading the
planet Earth was just something that he
couldn't handle and he actually kind of
drank himself into a stupor for about a
year so he really kind of tries to tell
Sally Floyd that her best bet here her
best role to not only I guess satisfy
her position as a reporter but to also
keep herself safe is to simply just
report the facts but Sally Floyd doesn't
really want to hear this and Sally Floyd
is avidly against registration she
thinks it's a violation of the
Constitution and so on and so forth and
so of course as a two-part ways Sally
really kind of makes the statement that
this registration didn't just kind of
appear out of nowhere it wasn't just
something that just kind of fell before
Congress because they all wanted to do
it that someone somewhere set these
things in motion and if you trace the
line far enough you
come to one person who has really kind
of set all these things in motion from
there we switch to Sally Floyd who is
again interviewing or I guess kind of
sitting in on a meeting with underground
superheroes now the number of
superheroes that she's meeting with now
have expanded to far more than they were
previously if you recall Civil War
frontline issue number three there were
individuals like Battlestar and typeface
and solo and a handful of others we see
now that the the group has expanded by
quite a bit and the group is more or
less kind of being led by a superhero
named network now network is really kind
of interesting she doesn't have any
inherent abilities per se that is to say
that she doesn't have powers that are
tied in to her biology the powers that
she has actually comes from a suit that
she wears and she's able to intercept I
guess the network communication she's
able to intercept cellphones and all
forms of data that are transmitted
throughout the planet Earth regardless
of how they're transmitted and they're
really kind of talking about the fact
that they want to get in touch with
Captain America's team because Captain
America's team is you know despite the
fact that it's really kind of engaging
in a lot of activities there are various
superheroes out there who are forming
their own underground but don't quite
know how to get in touch with it and
it's very tedious to try to do this and
the reason why is because with shield
really kind of watching everything that
everyone does it's difficult to really
kind of stick your head above the
surface and look around it's really kind
of a allegory so to speak to world war 1
where they used to say that the the
lifespan for anyone that stuck their
head above the trench was about 8
seconds now what we see as this really
kind of progresses as the story moves
forward is that someone had tipped
shield and Iron Man's team off to this
meeting that was going to take place and
they ambushed all the superheroes for
the most part a huge portion of them are
captured or killed and taken away but
some of the managed to escape among them
is Sally Floyd and Sally Floyd has
really kind of blamed for the invasion
the ambush of shield you know we see
solo really kind of screaming at Sally
Floyd saying that she's the one that
really tipped them off she's the one
that ratted them out of course we know
that or at least we believe for the most
part the Sally Floyd was not responsible
for this battle star tells gladiator
--ax this her job to make sure that
Sally Floyd gets to safety and the
reason why Sally Floyd is so important
here is because she is the unbiased
person she's the one person that could
actually tell the story of these
superheroes without having to
worry about any kind of ramifications
without having to worry about any kind
of incarceration because the press is
protected by the Constitution now as
things really kind of begin to progress
we see that six minutes after the ambush
took place that we kind of transitioned
to Ben Urich and Ben Urich is on the
phone with Sally fluid and Sally Floyd
voices her concerns that maybe somebody
followed her that maybe her phone was
being tapped that maybe something was
going on that we didn't really know at
the very least she didn't know that she
was leading people to where this meeting
was going to take place with these
superheroes but what we see as we follow
Ben Urich is that Ben Urich actually
discovers a box and inside this box is a
pumpkin that is really kind of one of
the traits one of the most well-known
aspects of the Green Goblin Norman
Osborn and then we see that in fact the
Green Goblin ambushes and confronts Ben
Urich and talks about how in previous
articles of Ben Urich had written he had
really kind of total lies about the
Green Goblin and Norman Osborn wants to
set these things straight from there we
switched to robbie baldwin and robbie
baldwin is in a boxing match with to me
and if you recall in our discussion with
civil war frontline issue number three
the Robbie Baldwin had been tormented
time and time again by to me more so
than any of the other prisoners and it
really kind of challenged to me as a way
to establish the fact that he's not
going to put up with this kind of abuse
anymore as the two of them are fighting
Robbie Baldwin is actually gaining the
upper hand because Robbie Baldwin as the
superhero speedball has had a lot of
skill when it came to hand-to-hand
combat and so to me is really just kind
of fighting with blind rage and using
his physical strength as a means to try
to topple his opponent robbie baldwin is
more he has more finesse he's really
kind of more athletic here and what we
see is that some of the other inmates
who have bet on to me to win are seeing
the fight kind of going against them
winning and so one of the teammates i'm
sorry one of the inmates actually cuts
the leg of Robbie Baldwin with a shiv
now we see Robbie Baldwin you know kind
of fall to the ground and so on and so
forth and actually to me steps on his
leg and breaks it but then we see that
for a fleeting moment
Robbie Baldwin manifests his abilities
and the entire boxing ring is destroyed
from there we transition to Robbie
Baldwin with his mother and his mother's
visiting him in prison and of course his
mother's really kind of an anguish here
she's angry because
we Baldwin will not accept any kind of
admission of guilt he will not do
anything to get himself out of prison
and to make amends for the actions at
Stamford Connecticut in addition we see
that Robbie Baldwin's father simply just
chose not to visit also Robbie's mother
is really kind of in a rough spot here
and the reason why is because for the
most part I wouldn't go as far as to say
that she's kind of being selfish here
she's really kind of in a position where
she has to hear people to you know talk
time and time again about how Robbie
Baldwin is such a horrible person and
that he was raised by horrible parents
that she along with her husband in
addition to Robbie Baldwin have just
kind of been ostracized by society as a
whole and so she really kind of says
that she's not coming back anymore that
she doesn't want to have to deal with
this anymore from there we switched to
detectives Heath and Donna and Keith and
Donna are really kind of following a law
in the investigation that we had picked
up with in a civil war front line issue
number three with the destruction of
Jo's marina and we had talked about how
Jo had really kind of I guess disguised
himself or was disguised as a human but
in fact he was actually an Atlantian and
what's really kind of funny here is that
Heath is really kind of talking to Donna
and talks about how he thinks that Jo
might be a Russian and Jonna really I'm
not really kind of thinks this is silly
she kind of really thinks this is a
little ridiculous but agrees to kind of
bite into it and see where keith is
going with it and what's really kind of
funny here is that Keith's entire
speculation falls alongside or falls
with the Calico panels as we see with
Namor the Submariner and Keith says that
he thinks that Jo was a sleeper agent
that at some point along the line he had
a subliminal message planted in his
brain and that the message was designed
to be triggered at some point in time
now while he's really kind of you know I
guess stating this in relation to Jo
being a Russian what we actually see
going on here is that Jo was an
Atlantian maybe a super spy of some kind
and that at some point a subliminal
message was implanted in his brain by
namer the Submariner and that when the
message was activated he would activate
as an Atlantean to carry out whatever
task it was that he was programmed to do
and as we see as the two of them are
kind of talking and they agree that it
really is kind of silly and ridiculous
we see that Jo the Atlantean is actually
disguised as a
butter and leaves the scene